der mensch wird gedruckt schicht für
schicht zur menschlichen haut wir
forscher geschafft haben mit hilfe eines
3d drucker die menschliche haut zu
konstruieren jetzt fertig zum
seitenwechsel essen aus dem radio kennen
wir gajic bauteile oder gar
präzisionswerkzeuge aus dem 3d drucker
im weltraum gedruckt auch das kennen wir
bereits komplexe funktionelle gewebe wie
die menschliche haut wie er bei den
druck erstellen das ist allerdings ein
ganz anderes level ein level das
herkömmliche medizinische verfahren
aussticht und ganz neue möglichkeiten
offenbar spanische forscher stellten im
fachmagazin biological ihren neu
entwickelten 3d bio drucker vor mit dem
drucker weit möglich die zwei äußeren
hautschichten des menschen kostengünstig
und voll funktionstüchtig zu produzieren
sie hätten sich sogar selbstständig nach
einer transplantation bei mäusen mit den
anderen hautzellen verein zu dem äußeren
zwei schichten der menschlichen haut
gehören die epidermis und die wärme auch
wenn es nur die zwei äußern schichten
sind und auch hier schon viel geleistet
werden die ip damit zum beispiel hat
zwar keine gefäße oder nervenzellen
dafür aber hoch spezialisierte andere
zählen die sogenannten keratinozyten
bilden mit der hornburg dampf keratin
das schutzschild der menschlichen haut
schon der uns die wärme genauer an
da wird klar warum das ganze
letztendlich wirklich revolutionär ist
die wärme besteht nämlich aus
blutgefäßen haarfollikeln erfolg und den
schweißdrüsen und all das mit einem
einzigen fell drucker produzieren war
zitat diese methode des bios drucks
erlaubt es menschliche haut in
standardisierter weise und automatisiert
zu produziert und ist zudem weniger
teuer als herkömmliche verfahren der
zellkultur so alfredo brisach von der
bio dann group in der praxis kann diese
methoden großes leisten beispielsweise
könnte man damit mit meinen fällen meine
eigene haut drucken und diese dann bei
verletzung ein
anstatt tierversuchen könnte man
menschliche haut einfach so herstellen
um diese zu versuchszwecken zu nutzen
und es wird ja noch mehr gedruckt dazu
hier klicken
dazu gibt es ein weiteres video zum 3d
druck von organen da wenn euch das video
gefallen hat vergessen dass ihr nicht
daumen nach oben ein kostenloses abo
dafür hier klicken und gibt es noch mehr
einsatzmöglichkeiten wenn ja welche
lasst es mich in den kommentaren wissen
was habt ihr für ideen und glaubt ihr
dass man irgendwann einen kompletten
mensch drucken kannst du komische idee
ansonsten ich würde mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran